bonsoir beau bonsoir jeune homme c'est
vous la fais de la puberté monsieur
comment est-ce que tu m'a appelé le fait
de la puberté monsieur je suis hörmann
monsters je suis juste passé pour ma
livraison quotidienne de pollution
nocturne dans toutes les vidéos
éducatives la puberté des garçons c'est
toujours le miracle de l'éjaculation
non non je me suis jamais arrosé comme
ça et pour les filles c'est une marée
histoire des tuyauteries périodiquement
douloureux mon dieu
quoi hier soir j'ai vu lepéniste mais à
quoi tu joues au cours du verre est donc
aujourd'hui tu as peur d'être un
homosexuel mais un homme peut toucher le
pénis d'un autre homme feuillerat là où
même l'embrasser avec délicatesse
ok
la quille tu devrais l'invité à sortir
pourquoi tu dis ça parce que je passe ma
vie à rêver des filles qui ne veulent
pas de moi et vu que celle ci se
présente devrait sauter sur l'occasion
c'est clair j'ai peur c'est toute la
ville il est super g il y à un autre
encore à l'arrière mais je vois la
réserve pour un anniversaire ce gamin
est un génie
les filles sont sexy t elle ce aussi
aussi obsédés que les gars apparemment
quand une idée de ce que je veux de sac
à merde
du rêve d'être maquillée toi tu veux
écouter lana del rey en boucle pendant
que tu découpes les manches des tee
shirts et toi tu es sur les retraites
comme de mary hurler de rire pendant
qu'elles furent tous peuvent bien ma
chérie casse toi tout de suite ça nan
casse toi
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on y va
et bien moi je suis deux parties
génitales salut moi c'est du 600ème asie
c'est en fait tu fais pas peur donc à
c'était pas trop fort et j'ai trouvé ce
passage un peu déplaisant ouais mais il
ya un moment où c'était marrant non
j'aime bien les trucs bizarres mais pas
ça fait netflix qui a insisté pour
lemaitre sait rien ouais
dutcher ça
m